bonjour arnaud bénézis merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors le président de
la république 1 et à mulhouse
aujourd'hui sa première sortie
médiatique depuis dix jours maintenant
et les annonces du confinement
emmanuel macron est il tout simplement à
la hauteur de la crise
écoutez c'est difficile de le dire pour
l'instant dans la mesure où on est et au
plein milieu de cette crise bat son
plein du au début de cette crise ce qui
est sûr c'est que on voit que sa cote de
confiance en tout cas la cote de
confiance qui était celle de l'exécutif
qui était annoncé par un sondage et lab
était une cote de confiance plutôt
positive c'était fléchi depuis quelques
jours la polémique sur les masques la
polémique sur la chloroquine la
polémique sur le manque de moyens faut
douter bien évidemment une opinion
publique qui est aujourd'hui consignes
et ses ailes et il va de soi que pour
emmanuel macron il ya la nécessité
aujourd'hui d'intervenir pour rassurer
les français surtout pour leur expliquer
quelles seront les prochaines mesures
que l'exécutif compte cambrin pour le
permettre
quelque part de contraindre la
propagation de cette de cette épidémie
emmanuel macron lisait aujourd'hui du
côté de mulhouse assure le premier
hôpital militaire de campagne du pays
dans une région encore une fois
particulièrement touchés est ce que à la
présence du chef de l'état est
nécessaire selon van là bas la
symbolique est forte parce que l'est
d'abord a payé un très lourd tribut à
cette épidémie depuis maintenant
plusieurs plusieurs jours que le client
la république s'était engagé à ce que
cet hôpital de campagne viennent
soulager l'hôpital public dans l'est et
puis il ya quelque part une référence
historique vous savez l'est c'est une
une région qui historiquement a beaucoup
souffert qui a beaucoup souffert des
guerres et donc ils essayent de
réactiver cette figure du père de la
nation un peu à la clémence au qui
allait soutenir ces poilus dans les
tranchées toutes choses étant égales par
ailleurs
même il faut le signaler aussi mais
c'est en tout cas le chef de l'état qui
veut montrer qu'il est aujourd'hui
pleinement concentré sur sa tâche au
moment encore une fois où les français
sont confinés où certaine forme de
défiance se commence à s'installer dans
l'opinion publique
quant à la façon dont l'exécutif a géré
cette crise depuis finalement le le
début de la crise nous sommes toujours
avec arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
merci d'être resté avec nous arnaud
benedetti on a entendu un emmanuel
macron avec un champ lexical de l'unité
c'est vraiment ça qu'on va retenir de ce
discours
oui c'est un président de la république
qui a compris que aujourd'hui la
confiance n'était plus forcément au
rendez-vous dans la société et dans
l'opinion publique française après tout
un ensemble de polémiques qui ont
égrainé l'actualité de ces derniers
jours au sujet du coït 19
qu'il s'agisse de la polémique des
masques qu'il s'agisse de la polémique
sur la chloroquine il s'agit de la
polémique sur le manque de moyens et il
y avait quelque part si vous voulez un
ton qui étaient un ton à la fois en
effet très grave très mobilisateur mais
aussi inquiet dans la déclaration du
président a publié comme s'il sentait
pour reprendre une vieille expression
qu'avait utilisé notre chef d'état dans
des temps plus obscur un certain vent
mauvais qui s'installait dans le pays
qu'il fallait répondre à la fois en
soutenant ceux qui sont en première
ligne c'est à dire les soignants qui
depuis maintenant des semaines se battre
sur le front du virus et font part de
leurs inquiétudes par rapport au manque
criant de moyens voire à la pénurie
sanitaires à laquelle ils sont
confrontés
mais il n'était aussi dans le registre
j'essaie de réparer parfois les gaffes
d'un certain nombre de ministres écouter
ce qu'ils disent sur les enseignants
tout juste quelques heures rappelé la
déclaration pour parole
de la porte parole du gouvernement sur
les enseignants disons que les
enseignants de travailler pendant ce
moment alors qu'il travaille on voyait
bien que c'était un président de la
république qui cherchait à eux aussi 4
ise un certain nombre de blessures qui
avait vu le jour ces dernières heures et
c'est ces derniers jours donc il a
également et ça c'est peut-être le plus
important a lancé quelques mesures
concrètes vous avez parlé du plan
résidence mais aussi des mesures pour
l'hôpital en la lançant un grand plan
d'investissements massifs dans l'hôpital
une fois la crise surmontée
c'est un moyen aussi pour lui de
répondre aux critiques qui émanent
aujourd'hui de la plupart des
professionnels de santé sur la logique
comptable qui a été celle de la gestion
de l'hôpital public depuis un certain
nombre d'années et dont il est à la fois
aussi l'héritier mais aussi l'exécutant
depuis deux ans et demi a nominé
n'étions le disais tout à l'heure le
président de la république ne s'est pas
exprimé depuis dix jours maintenant et
ses annonces sur les mesures de
confinement
il a dit cette fois qu'il reviendrait
dans quelques jours est ce que une
dizaine de jours l'absurde l'absence du
chef de l'état ou en tout cas de de sa
parole a été un peu longue
je ne suis pas sûr parce que sa parole a
été relayée notamment par le premier
ministre et le ministre de la santé même
en situation de crise
un président un chef d'état doit être en
mesure d'économiser ses mots pour tours
à retrouvé le moment opportun où il faut
s'exprimer parce que plus il s'exprimera
dans cette crise plus sa parole sera ou
moins sa parole sera entendue donc il
faut qu'ils conservent aussi une
économie de moyens en matière de
communication sauf que le problème
auquel il est confronté c'est que la
communication de l'exécutif depuis le
début de cette crise est une
communication qui donne lieu parfois à
des messages et c'était là
je mange observé par nombre d'experts et
de commentateurs à des messages
contradictoires donc tout se passe comme
s'il fallait un moment donné que le
président de la république revienne en
première ligne pour redonner de la
cohérence au message de l'exécutif c'est
une difficulté supplémentaire à laquelle
aujourd'hui est confronté l'exécutif et
la tête de l'exécutif dans la gestion de
cette de cette crise merci beaucoup
arnaud benedetti d'avoir été à chez nous
ce soir sur arte france rappelle que
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
à politique et parlementaire merci
beaucoup